Welcome to the Loser Lounge,...
...where emojis who never get used hang out.
What's up, High Five?
I'm an emoji, I gotta have some sort of purpose here.
I'm gonna help you.
We need to get off the phone and find the source code.
Then I can fit in!
Let's roll.
Bye, Felicia.
First, we have to get through this firewall.
What's Alex's girlfriend's name again?
It was...
Tina.
Access Denied.
Karen.
Sarah.
I wanna say Lupita but that doesn't feel right now I'm saying it out loud.
I think you're pretty cool just the way you are.
Nobody leaves the phone.
Delete them!
My feelings are huge.
Maybe I'm meant to have more than just one emotion.
Where am I?
Candy crush.
Divine.
Sweet.
Tasty.
Delicious.
I'm never eating another piece of candy ever again.
High Five, don't do it.
Don't you do it, it's already been in there once.